Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
It has been a while now since we've talked
about fluid simulations, and now, it is time
for us to have a look at an amazing technique
that creates simulations with viscoelastic
fluids, plus rigid and deformable bodies.
This is a possibility with previous techniques
but takes forever to compute and typically
involves computational errors that add up
over time and lead to a perceptible loss of
viscoelasticity.
I'll try to explain these terms and what's
going on in a moment.
There will be lots of eye candy to feast your
eyes on throughout the video, but I can assure
you that this scene takes the cake.
The simulation phase here took place at one
frame per second, which is still not yet fast
enough for the much coveted real-time applications,
however, is super competitive compared previous
off-line techniques that could do this.
So what does viscosity mean?
Viscosity is the resistance of a fluid against
deformation.
Water has a low viscosity and rapidly takes
the form of the cup we pour it into, where
honey, ketchup and peanut butter have a higher
viscosity and are much more resistant to these
external forces.
Elasticity is a little less elusive concept
that describes to what degree a piece of fluid
behaves like elastic solids.
However, viscous and elastic are not binary
yes or no concepts, there is a continuum between
the two, and if we have the proper machinery,
we can create viscoelastic fluid simulations.
The tau parameter that you see here controls
how viscous or elastic the fluid should be,
and is referred to in the paper as relaxation
time.
As tau is increased towards infinity, the
friction dominates the internal elastic forces
and the polymer won't be able to recover its
structure well.
The opposite case is where we reduce the tau
parameter to zero, then, the internal elastic
forces will dominate and our polymer will
be more rigid.
The alpha parameter stands for compliance,
which describes the fluidity of the model.
Using a lower alpha leads to more solid behavior,
and higher alphas lead to more fluid behavior.
The cool thing is that as a combination of
these two parameters, we can produce a lot
of really cool materials ranging from viscous
to elastoplastic to inviscid fluid simulations.
Have a look at this honey pouring scene.
Mmmm!
This simulation uses more than a 100 thousand
particles and 6 of these frames can be simulated
in just 1 second.
Wow.
If we reduce the number of particles to a
few tens of thousands, real-time human interaction
with these simulations also becomes a possibility.
A limitation of this technique is that most
of our decisions involving the physical properties
of the fluid are collapsed into the tau and
alpha parameters, if we are looking for more
esoteric fluid models, we should look elsewhere.
I am hoping that since part of the algorithm
runs on the graphics card, the speed of this
technique can be further improved in the near
future.
That would be awesome.
Admittedly, we've only been scratching the
surface, so make sure to have a look at the
paper for more details.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!